hey guys it's Justine and oh my goodness
I had so much fun at WDC and not only
did I have a really great time at the
event but I had a lot of fun meeting so
many of you guys I posted several videos
if you guys haven't checked those out I
went to two Apple stores in Cupertino I
went to the one infinite loop store and
I went to the visitors center I posted a
video using emoji and I also posted
another video it was just a vlog of my
sister kind of following me around WWDC
so it's kind of like you guys were there
with me at the Apple store I bought this
leather iPhone case it's beautiful it's
kind of like a salmon color I've never
had a leather iPhone case before this is
my first one so I kind of had to give in
because this case was right next to like
an electric blue color which was my
sister's favorite color and the salmon
is my favorite color so I got us
matching cases and I got us Apple watch
bands to match it was kind of like my
gift for saying Jenna thank you for
filming for me all day let's take a look
and see oh wow well this looks really
good I think I might have to get my
nails painted that color I'll think
about it I thought about it I'll do it I
also got this Apple watch band it's very
nice but watch os5 really really excited
about it the walkie talkie feature is
gonna be so fun I'm probably gonna annoy
the heck out of my sister and probably
annoy any other friends that give me a
kisses to be able to walkie-talkie them
on my watch
so I install the iOS 12 beta and I'm
loving it so far it's crazy how stable
it is because usually like the first
iteration of an iOS is not very stable
so far it's been awesome one of the
things that has already made my life so
much better is group notifications so as
you can see here my sister just texted
me several times
okaywell needs me to unlock that is my
face so when you press and click into it
you can see the messages that you
received hey Justine hello what do you
think will get for dinner tomorrow
forget we're obsessed with spaghetti so
when you click on those three dots this
will bring up this little tab here and
this will let you adjust your
notifications accordingly deliver
quietly turn it off or you can go in to
get more settings so a lot of the
complaints and issues that we all had in
iOS 11 a lot of those are now officially
being resolved in iOS 12 of course again
this is still in beta so it won't be out
into the fall for everyone obviously one
of the highlights is the MIMO jeez it's
so silly but there's so much fun
so maybe soup but jenna is still sending
me messages
making a video so I made this meme og a
little bit ago my other one that I made
a WDC I had curly hair but now I'm back
to my straight hair again hey Jenna
how's it going I love spaghetti I also
love soup see we like licking the soup
out of the bowl because now there's
tongue detection there's one of the
funniest thing is whenever they
announced the feature of tongue
detection it sounds really really silly
but I'll tell you what you guys are not
gonna tell me that there is up in many
many times that you've used in emojis
and you've stuck your tongue out and
nothing has happened so it kind of only
is a natural progression so I approve of
it so there's a few new ant emojis we
have the tiger hello I'm a tiger
there's the koala bear look how cute I
love the Koala I think general like this
hey Jenna I'm a koala
we got the Koala has a tongue too this
is so weird t-rex hey Jenna when are we
gonna go see Jurassic world did you know
that the park is gone I'm gonna be so
annoying no friends will be safe in iOS
12 one of the things that has already
slightly been driving me crazy is
usually when you click on the camera app
it'll give you the option to go into
your camera library but instead you have
to click on a little photo icon right
there and that will bring up your photos
so it's fine again not an ideal
situation okay so here is I showed you
guys this in the other video I did about
the G but I'm gonna show you guys
again this is my Anna mode Wow why does
my head look so big this is so silly
okay let's take a picture okay how do I
look oh it looks just basic oh I'm
making a video
oops okay well I'm making a video this
is me so still all new to me because I
just
okay well whoops oh my gosh this is me
without the an emoji on my head oh my
god I don't want to see it I don't want
to see it I'm embarrassed you can add
things let's see what's this oh look at
that and it's great because you can just
like pin them places too so it's kind of
like snapchat I'll pin that they're
pretty accurate
let's put an arrow this is one of my
favorite stickers it's so stupid it's
called poop troop they're just they're
little pooping stickers I don't know I
have a problem but of course you don't
have the iJustine stickers look at that
there's me I'm sticking myself all over
the place of course there's a poop the
coffee right well I guess I'll take a
picture of myself now what have I done
so here is my screen time this is out of
5 hours and 44 minutes wait a minute no
that's how much I've used my phone I
thought that was just out of the past 5
hours but I don't know that's that's how
much I've used my phone so I've been in
messages for an hour and 19 minutes
I've been social networking for 35
minutes I've been on Twitter for 29
minutes and other for an hour and 54
minutes so let's go and look in here
messages so shouldn't reckon what is the
productivity Oh with the insta 361 I'm
doing a video on that I've picked up my
phone 12 times per hour
277 pickups you guys can see here
there's a little bit of a gap right
there I took a nap so that's why there's
no activity here's notifications there's
around 14 per hour 108 messages YouTube
tips interesting this is all very
interesting yeah that's when I took my
nap from five to six that's why there
was no activity I installed this around
noon today so after a week I would love
to give you guys an update to see what
my usage is actually like because today
was kind of like a weird day I've been
shooting a lot of videos and kind of
running around doing a lot of stuff so I
haven't really been on my phone as much
as I normally think that I would so
that's definitely gonna be something
that's gonna be terrifying to see how
much time you really are spending on
your devices so no huge iOS 12 update is
stability and speed this is up to 75%
faster cameras light with 50% faster
keyboard displayed up to two times
faster app launched under heavy workload
beutel's of face time up to 32 people
which I don't think that I have 32
people that have of iOS 12 beta
installed yet so we're gonna try that
another time they've also updated photos
so there is supposedly like a better
search suggestion I really only search
my photos for photos of dogs so if you
guys didn't know that you could do that
you can find me photos of dogs there are
1,500 pictures of dog
on my iPhone right now so it's great as
you can search by selfies bursts live
photos or videos as you can see there's
as I said a fifteen hundred and
forty-four photos of dogs oh look
there's categories there's dogs hot dogs
and coach dogs what does that mean hot
dogs okay this actually has pictures of
hot dogs this is from a super old video
why is this even on my phone and soon
July 4th 2015
oh this is May 2nd 2015 that's not a hot
dog those are actually fried Oreos but
hey nice try okay let's search for a pig
oh my gosh I have a lot of pigs these
are my favorite pigs ever this is prissy
Pig this is actually a photo from March
1st 2015
oh these are my favorite pigs ever
here's a pig card here's a pig in a cat
here's a pig smiling I'll search for
Tahoe when we went to Tahoe so there's
some pictures from Tahoe how about
Hawaii
there's Hawaii pictures what about
Pittsburgh Wow so these pictures are
like really old this is crazy
oh did I ever tell you guys I filmed a
movie well here's spoiler alert here's
me in the movie we filmed that December
20th 2017 it's gonna be a cool movie I'm
very excited about it
here's some old technology that I was
using in the movie so Siri shortcuts is
also something that I'm really
interested in so you can make specific
recipes for things that you want to do
so if I tell Syria that hey I'm on my
way home I can set up a shortcut to text
my sister have my lights turn on change
the temperature really whatever you can
get your phone to do you can have Siri
do that for you
haven't really had a chance to mess with
shortcuts very much yet so I can't
really speak too much on it but as I
play with iOS 12 a little bit more I'm
sure I will talk more about that in a
future video let me know what you guys
think of iOS 12 have you installed it
yet or like so many of you guys keep
asking how you get access to these betas
to download on your phone if you have an
Apple Developer account you can download
different profiles onto your phone so
that allows you to download beta
software so it's not something that is
easily accessible for everyone
I don't have the watch I was 5 beta
installed but I did go to yoga today and
I even forgot my watch so I was like
even if I wanted to track it I wouldn't
even have been able to I'm excited about
all of the new gym kit features you can
track yoga hiking but mostly man walkie
talkie is gonna be fun well thank you
guys for watching I'll see you
next video by
you